[موسيقى]
ينزل علينا المطر من السحاب والغمام
والمعصرات فالسحاب ماخوذه من سحب الشيء
فهي تسحب لنا الماء من مكان الى مكان اخر
بحبل الرياح والغمام ماخوذه من الغمه وهي
الغطاء فهي تغطي وجه السماء عنا والعامه
يسمون سقف المنزل بلغما واحيانا تحصر
الرياح اللواقه الغمامه في زاويه واحده
وتعصر ما في جوفها من مياه فتسمى المعصرات
ليت الغمام الذي عندي صواعقه يزيلهن الى
من عنده الدين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ومن باب العموم السحب تنقسم الى قسمين سحب
صيفيه وسحب شتويه الصيفيه هي السحب
العابره وعاده ما تكون في طبقات الجو
العليا والعامه يسمونها بسحب العكسيه
لانها قادمه من جهه الشرق الى جهه الغرب
والسحب الشتويه وهي سحب الماطره وعاده ما
تكون في طبقات الجو والمتوسطه والدنيا
ارقت واصحابي قعود بربوه لبرق تلالا في
تهامه
لامعوا
[موسيقى]